hallo mein name ist luca und die spielen
heute mal master bilder viele denken
sich einfach weil ich das noch nie
gebracht habe dass sich das schlechteren
bin so wie in jedem anderen spieler aber
an alle nichtsnutzigen volltrottel hier
draußen ich bin master builders champion
glaubte mir nicht schau mal ob ich hier
irgendwann nach leider kann ich habe
sogar noch hier mein pokal von damals
pokal das ist mein pokal von den master
builders meistro das ist schon
tatsächlich ein bisschen her das war
1892 in ungarn das belegt quasi das ich
master builders boss bin ja sie haben
alle leute die das nicht zu laut nicht
nur für euch zukommen
ich mache jetzt mal komplett kaputt
ihren alle die master will das nicht
kennen das ist dieser modus den
derzeitigen wie jeder nur noch 15
youtube hochlädt ich jetzt auch ich
wollte ihn einfach mal zeigen wie es
funktioniert
wir sind jetzt in der welt drin und da
unten zielgerade ein countdown runter
wende abgelaufen das leben in der mitte
eingeblendet was wir jetzt innerhalb von
fünf minuten bauen müssen dass in diesem
fall jetzt ein green design die königin
der champion
wie stellt man hautfarbe hier da ich
mache das jetzt mal einfach mit diesem
blog hier erstmal bei der königin hier
vorne ein schönes kleid zu 542 das geht
dann hier so ein bisschen hoch damit die
auch natürlich sehen hey die sprint
festen courtney dies gar nicht
prinzessin dieser königin alles klar
nur noch 4 minuten aber natürlich klar
werde ich das schaffen das tier wird
jetzt quasi so dieser oh mein gott
wieso ist da wie die
he
das hier ist das gewand was die queen
tragen wird und das ist natürlich
komplett vergoldet weil sie unglaublich
geil und cool ist ja dass hier soll
jetzt das gesicht darstellen weil ich
überhaupt nicht weiß wie man hautfarbe
diesem modus darstellen soll
beziehungsweise allgemeinen minecraft
das geht gar nicht dass hier werden die
augen
das heißt ich mache die hier so ein
bisschen rum hier da sind die augen dann
bekommt die noch eine tolle welcher
farbe mache jetzt die nase und dann noch
in rot die lippen von zwei minuten
ich muss mich da tatsächlich ein
bisschen bei allen das heißt es wird
wahrscheinlich nachher nicht schön
aussehen das liegt nicht daran dass ich
nicht malen kann bzw sind nicht hier
minecraft ausbauen kann sondern einfach
weil ja ich bin schlecht dann bekommt
die sonne oranges t shirt jetzt einfach
mal noch hier dran geklatscht so hier
bei mama mama das ist das t shirt an
alle die nicht glauben wollen also
wahrscheinlich keiner hat wir haben die
krone vergessen was ist eine königin
ohne krone man da also hier zack zack
zack das sieht jetzt aus wie ein hut
aber dafür mache ich oben einfach noch
hier so die beiden teile dran dann packe
ich da noch eben zwei diamant blogger
dran und hier zum leuchten
caramba ramberger
der finderlohn
wir können nur hoffen dass wir nicht
letzter werden kann man denn überhaupt
das ist ist das eine königin ich schreib
einfach unten drunter dass das mit queen
ist noch ganz schnell in 15 sekunden ich
hoffe dass das packe so sagt 87 sekunden
entsteht da geh ich dachte gerade mainz
erhältlich aber naja das ist auch nicht
so toll ich sag mal einfach ablegen und
wenn jetzt theoretisch alle sagen würden
meister bleeding dann wird dieses ding
in die luft fliegen das hier ist mala
bleeding es ist tatsächlich gerade die
luft geflogen
wir haben wir das ist auch mein ding
weil was ist das man merkt schon krass
dass andere youtuber wenn ihr das
irgendwie aufnehmen teilweise andere
einfach runter worden damit die den
ersten platz belegen ich weiß nicht was
das bringt vielleicht nicht bei der mehr
punkte aber ich habe auf dem server
keine frau
das ist richtig wieso bin ich nicht auf
die idee mit dieser hautfarbe gekommen
dennis aus sind es ist echt mega als
hier sogar die krone lose außenrum einer
dem das ist es mega chillig man hier ist
meine königin
da kann ich jetzt einmal ich glaube ich
kann man nicht sagen welche messing
nudel schreibt jetzt jetzt denkt das ist
für dieses bild hier ist habe ich
bestimmt nicht um korb sie tatsächlich
eigentlich auch ganz schön aus die augen
sind ganz cool mit diesem was ist das
denn hier
er ist das ist ja unglaublich
es ist einfach richtig schön wieso
konnte mich nicht auf die idee mit zum
mund hier haben wir
eine person die gerade pipi mal okay wtf
und ich glaube dass mein gott der hat
die gleiche die wie ich mein abi de
liegt das mini dorf liegt dass sie die
luft liegt es in die luft fliegt es in
die luft fliegt es in die luft fliegt es
in die luft fliegt
ich glaube das war jetzt auch schon der
letzte und jetzt haben wir das
endergebnis mac nudeln wir sind fünfter
nein ich meiner als jenny muss natürlich
sagen wenn euch diese folge master
builders gefallen hat und ihr denkt
jetzt ja der luca zeigt es mir mit einer
bewertung und ich werde das eventuell
vielleicht noch mal aufnehmen ich denke
zwar nicht weil ich schlecht bin aber
naja ich mal eben einen pokal